most women know better they know that a
man does not want a dominant alpha type
of woman like they know that i had a
woman tell me that she was looking for
michelle obama she wanted to be the
barack obama of her relationship and she
was looking for michelle she told me
this we were out on a date and you know
at that at that moment you got the bell
she wants to be the barack and she's
looking forward to the show
and you know that she is if she does
find that guy she is going to be so
unhappy exactly
she is gonna be miserable now why do you
think she'd be unhappy sterling well
because it's not in her nature to lead
the relationship yeah women do not want
to be they don't want that they're like
allergic to that responsibility in that
accountability yeah like
especially the accountability part like
women tend to want to defer to like the
group
think when it comes to making decisions
when they come that's why women on
social media tend to go along with
whatever the mainstream narrative is a
lot more often than men do that's why i
think roller always says that men are
more hierarchical okay we have the we
have the general then we've got the the
the lieutenant and the major and the
captain we get it yeah whereas women are
more communal social if you will yeah
the collectivism they want everything to
be equal you know and uh it's because
they don't have to live in competition
though like we have to compete for
reproduction so we're hardwired for
competition you know and that means that
we're hardwired to accept criticism
because the only way you can get better
is if you can accept criticism from your
boys how do you how do you process that
because women are also competing in the
sexual marketplace women
are want to look good they do their best
they want to look put on their makeup
put on their high handles they're out
there competing yeah but it's indirect
competition okay like a woman ain't
gonna if a nice-looking girl walks into
the room she's gonna compliment her but
to her friend she's gonna say something
you know to the side
it's because women are they compete but
it's indirectly it's a look at this yeah
so you know it's just a different kind
of competition for men it's a blood
sport
you know it makes me think you've seen
uh obviously you've seen friday we've
all seen it right
when she's like hey how you doing girl
it's like look at this hole
you know this part right okay
um i think i think it's also because
like men
like people talk about you know women
selecting men and i mean women being the
sexual selectors right in relationships
right where men just take what they can
get but the reality is that men
actually kind of select each other
like you put a group of men together and
they'll naturally figure out who's the
top dog like will men self-select into a
hierarchy and then women step back and
take a look at what the men have done
and be like okay that guy's the top dog
that's why women
but do you guys look like look at that
when like you look at a group of girls
do you look at them and say hmm which
one is the head one no no no no no no no
no woman is attractive she's attractive
you don't care you know what's funny
because i live in south beach i have a
bar in south beach i'm out there i
always run into like a flock of girls i
call it and i use flock um
respectfully you know they're flocking
around right
and i'm always like hey ladies what are
you guys up to tonight or what are you
guys up to this weekend you know maybe
i'll be with a couple of my boys or
whatever or maybe at my bar whatever we
got going on and i'll kind of like look
around and i'll always be like who's the
leader of the group here and they'll
always know oh she is
yeah so i'll kind of all look around and
be like yep sarah's and like sit and
like sarah be like yeah like what's up
like yes so the women know
that that there's a certain girl calling
the shots within that group is that kind
where you're going with this or what yes
would you say that that's generally the
one that's the most masculine though oh
yeah the most outspoken most dominant
yeah
yeah it's usually not the prettiest one
yeah that's the one that's the most dumb
correct it's the one that's going to
[ __ ] block you the most too
that's what we look at
so if you like that clip click right
here to watch another or if you want to
watch the entire sauce cast click right
here
[Music]